Le RN aurait quasiment la même politique que Macron,
1 politique autoritaire et 1 égalitaire.
Dans cette vidéo, on va s'appuyer sur des faits,
même si ça va faire mal au cul à certains de
reconnaître 1 vérité.
On va reprendre ce que le RN a voté,
ou plutôt n'a pas voté,
pour ne pas améliorer le quotidien de
nombreux citoyens.
Vu qu'on est dans le thème ces temps-ci,
on va aller
regarder du côté du Parlement européen où est élu Jojo,
le jeune facho.
En deux-mille-vingt,
le RN vote contre 1 résolution visant accéléré
la réduction des
écarts de salaire entre les hommes et les femmes.
Sans surprise,
ils votent également contre 1 résolution qui condamne
toutes les formes de racisme.
En deux-mille-vingt-et-un,
il vote contre l'accès gratuit
légal à l'avortement pour tous les femmes de lieu
et contre 1 rapport
qui condamne toutes les formes de violence
faite aux femmes.
Mesdames, Marine et Jordan sont au p'tit soin avec vous.
En deux-mille-vingt-trois,
ils ont voté contre 1 loi
sur la restauration de la nature en Europe.
Après ça, c'est pas étonnant, depuis des années,
ils votent contre tout ce qui peut aller dans le sens
de l'écologie
à l'Assemblée nationale en France,
préparez-vous le RN.
Comme le gouvernement actuel
s'acharne sur les français,
ils ont voté contre le blocage du prix pour les
produits de 1ère nécessité,
ils ont voté contre l'augmentation du SMIC
et contre le gel des loyers pour les particuliers,
TPE et PME aussi. 1 paradoxe.
Ceux qui sont venus dernièrement se présenter en
défenseur des paysans,
ils ont voté contre le fait d'indéminiser
les agriculteurs
victimes de catastrophe naturelle,
ils ont voté également
contre l'augmentation
des épergements pour les sans-abris.
Après en observant 1 partie de leur électorat,
je pense qu'ils en ont rien à foutre de ça.
Ils n'ont pas voté pour la taxation des superprofis,
on voté contre l'augmentation
des moyens pour lutter contre la fraude fiscale.
Bah tu m'étonnes quand tu connais leur magouille
de campagne.
Pour terminer autour de nos services publics,
ils ont voté contre l'augmentation des salaires
pour les soignants
et les pompiers,
on voté contre l'augmentation des moyens à louer
aux hôpitaux
et recrutements dans ses métiers en tension.
Ce qui est fou
c'est qu'il y a encore des gens qui croient en ces
charlatans alors qu'on a 1 bon exemple en Italie,
que ce genre de crapule dévoué au traité européen
ne font rien de plus,
rien de moins que les libéraux qu'ils critiquent
alors qu'ils défendent au final les mêmes intérêts,
ceux de la classe dominante.